our masters of cocktails and ceremonies
man i mean how does it feel to have a
bigger role on paradise this season
yeah i mean i was telling someone else
it's kind of like when your boss is like
guess what okay we're gonna need you to
like
this is exciting work a whole lot more
and you're like yes promotion and then
they're like but also no like you're
just still
making drinks yeah there's at the barn
on earth like and then we'll see what
happens you know
no it was so much fun i mean
i'm always awake when rose ceremonies
are happening
they're at night and i'm bartending for
everybody and so i'm always like in the
wings just like watching like
and so now i get to be like on screen
being like who's gonna get it
i have the power
no i
wasn't drunk with power no no just drunk
nor you know i did hear you making me
margarita yeah i try my best i suppose
my favorite is when and everyone will
inevitably do it they'll be like i like
a spicy margarita and i'm like all right
you said something yeah all right let's
see what happens to your butthole
tomorrow let's go and uh and so they
never order that again speaking of spicy
margaritas i saw you and sarah here is
this like a typical date night now i
think they're starting to open up things
like this no this is like okay first of
all like
she's only here to support me
and
also i think she only came because she
was like this is an excuse to like have
to get dressed up we haven't left the
house in a year and a half other than
like going to work so she's drinking a
mai tai somewhere right
she's living their best life she's like
i'm not doing any press i'm taking three
pictures for instagram and then i'm
going to the bar
you guys have a system down uh all right
so obviously you are master of
ceremonies this season but there's also
a lot of celeb guest hosts who stopped
by and crashed the party what was it
like to rub elbows elbows with them yeah
it was fun weirdly enough i had i had
personal relationships with a lot of
them beforehand yeah
so it was fun to like get to hang out
with them
i mean david's been
i'm just a huge fan of all his work um
and so i
quoted a lot of his movies to him
incorrectly i found out like he would be
like that's not the line you know uh and
then i'll be like i know i want to know
more like chris farley's stories can you
tell me could you tell me some chris
farley story any good one he would yes
and they were it was so cool to hear him
talk about you know that the scene where
it's like
housekeeping
housekeeping chris farley does that to
david spade in tommyboy and and and
spade was telling me that he wrote that
joke
but he's like when i did it wasn't funny
but if chris did it it was amazing i was
like
that's an iconic scene i know i love it
but anyways they were all the all the uh
guest uh celebrity hosts were amazing uh
titus was hilarious he never stopped
singing i don't even know if he can talk
he'll mix things uh little john brought
so much freaking energy um i i love
having that guy around
uh obviously lance is amazing
quite the lineup it was amazing it was
fun yeah you know obviously from the
promo we see a lot of tears we can
always expect a lot of drama with
paradise but who causes the most drama
this season
um i think we released that demi's on
the show so
you know um yeah the demigod comes out
and um
cakes were never the same after demi
showed up at the beach
yeah
i don't know what i'm allowed to say
contractually but you're right
were there multiple cakes or just one
cake that's what i'm trying to figure
out was it just one big one that just
all of a sudden was a dumpster fire is
this what you're talking about from the
teaser yes
she like dumps the cake
into the phone yeah no i was there
and then were you like shook
yeah well first of all she was gonna
throw in the ocean and i said hey go
throw in the fire no you didn't uh and
then she did it and then i said i guess
it uh needed a couple more minutes in
the oven i had a couple good jokes
they'll cut it out don't worry uh but
anyways
we were all bummed because we wanted
some cake
and it was just gone yeah it was like a
couple seasons ago when i i think it was
derek someone was walking with
uh walking with pizza and then a pizza
fell in the sand we were all like we
were waiting for the pizza
oh then derek ate it with the sand in it
so yeah it was one of those things we
were like dude we just wanted some pizza
or we just wanted some cake queen
victoria was telling me that she thinks
you should be the next host of bachelors
in paradise and then she can be the
bartender
okay are you down for that yeah sure um
have you had a drink made by her yet i
haven't
so i don't know if she's any good at it
but to be fair i'm not very good at it
either
would you be down to be the host of vip
sure yeah why not i loved you on there
they told me
well yeah that's because
when the drinks are free you love the
guy that's giving them out man
just keep giving out the drinks that
season that's it all right sounds good i
like it
[Music]